>> Tucker: TURNS OUT LOTS OF
DEMOCRATS ARE FRIENDS WITH
LOUIS FARRAKHAN.
CONGRESSMAN DANNY DAVIS OF
ILLINOIS CALLS HIM AN
OUTSTANDING HUMAN BEING,
SAID THAT TO A REPORTER FROM
DAILY CALLER.
SMILED AS HE DID.
EVEN BARACK OBAMA HAS BEEN
PHOTOGRAPHED MEETING WITH
MINISTER FARRAKHAN.
BUT MR. FARRAKHAN HAS A
COMPLICATED HISTORY.
HE HAS, AMONG OTHER THINGS
PRAISED ADOLF HITLER.
HE SAID WHITE PEOPLE DESERVE
TO DIE.
HE BLAMES THE JEWS FOR 9/11.
FOR SOME REASON NOBODY ON
MORNING JOE SEEMS TO NOTICE.
WHY IS THAT THAT MARK STEYN
IS AN AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
TO PUT THIS IN CONTEXT FOR
YOU DUKES OF HAZARD POPULAR.
PULLED OUT OF ROTATION
BECAUSE THERE IS A
CONFEDERATE FLAG ON A CAR.
THAT WAS CONSIDERED TOO
MUCH.
>> ON THE ROOF OF THE CAR.
>> Tucker: ON THE ROOF.
>> FOR THE SENSIBILITY OF
AMERICAN VIEWERS.
PROTECT THE CHILDREN FOR
THAT DAVIS HANGING OUT WITH
A GUY SAYING THE JEWS ARE
BLOOD SUCKERS OR HORRIBLE
THINGS.
NO ONE CARES BECAUSE OF WHY.
>> BECAUSE HE IS ON THEIR
TEAM.
THE LEFT ARE VERY SERIOUS
ABOUT THIS.
MINISTER FARRAKHAN HAS SAID
THAT INSTEAD OF BORING ON
ABOUT WHAT HITLER DID TO THE
JEW US, THE JEWS SHOULD ASK
THEM SELVES ABOUT WHAT THEY
DID TO HITLER TO MAKE HIM SO
MAD AT THEM.
>> Tucker: DID HE REALLY SAY
THAT?
COME ON.
>> THAT'S HOW HE HAS
FORMULATED IT ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS.
THE MEDIA AND POWERFUL
DEMOCRATS, SUCH AS THE
DEPUTY CHAIRMAN KEITH
ELLISON LOOKED THE OTHER
WAY.
THEY HAVE LOOKED THE OTHER
WAY SINCE AT LEAST THE
SO-CALLED MILLION MAN MARCH,
WHEN HE WENT NUTS AND
STARTED TALKING ON THE MILE
THAT HE WAS STANDING BY THE
LINCOLN AND JEFFERSON
MEMORIALS AND LINCOLN WAS
THE 16TH PRESIDENT AND
JEFFERSON WAS THE 3RD
PRESIDENT AND IF YOU ADD
THEM UP 16 AND 3 MAKES 19.
WHICH IS THE PRECISE HEIGHT
OF EACH OF THE MEMORIALS AND
19, THE 9 MEANS THERE IS A
PREGNANT WOMB AND THE 1
MEANS THERE IS A SECRET
THAT'S GOING TO BE
UNCOVERED.
HE IS A NUT.
NOW, IT'S NOT JUST THAT HE
HATES JEWS, BUT HE CLAIMS TO
HAVE BEEN ABDUCTED ON, I
BELIEVE, TWO OCCASIONS BY
ALIENS.
THE FIRST TIME HE WAS TAKEN
UP INTO SPACE TO COMMUNE
WITH THE SPIRIT OF ELIJAH
MUHAMMAD, THE FOUNDER OF THE
NATION OF ISLAM AND THE
SECOND TIME HE WAS
APPARENTLY ABDUCTED BY JEWS
WHO GOT AN UFO.
THERE IS JEWS IN SPACE.
WHO KNEW?
SO IT MEANS THAT WHENEVER
JARED KUSHNER OR TONY BLAIR
OR WHOEVER MIDDLE EAST PEACE
PROCESS THEY HAVE TO GET
RIGHT ON MINISTER
FARRAKHAN'S ROCKET SHIP AND
GO UP TO THE PLANET AND SORT
OUT THE SQUABBLING JUST AND
NATION OF ISLAM GUYS UP
THERE IN SPACE.
IT SAYS SOMETHING ABSOLUTELY
APPALLING ABOUT THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY THAT AN OBVIOUS NUT,
THAT OBAMA, THAT EVEN MAXINE
WATERS, THE KEITH ELLISON,
THAT ALL THESE DEMOCRATS ARE
SO SCARED OF A LUNATIC THAT
THEY FEEL OBLIGED TO KISS UP
TO HIM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S USEFUL.
I COVERED THE MILLION MAN
MARCH.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANY OF THAT.
WELL, THAT WAS AMAZING.
CRAZIER THAN I IMAGINED.
>> YEAH, IT'S ALL IN THE
NUMBERS.
16 PLUS 3:  LOOK, HE MAKES
GREAT ALBUMS OR DID IN THE
50'S.
AND HE CAN CARRY OFF A RED
BOW TIE WITH A PLUMB, WHICH
AS YOU KNOW, TUCKER, IS MORE
DIFFICULT THAN IT LOOKS.
SO LET'S GIVE HIM THAT.
BUT IT'S EMBARRASSING THAT
THIS NUT IS A POWER BROKER
IN THE DEMOCRAT PARTY AND
THE MEDIA WON'T COVER IT.
>> Tucker: OH, I WISH WE HAD